when you design for a specific place do
you actually go there physically or is
it enough for you to just see pictures
on the internet can you taste almost
smell a place just by a picture or do
you really need to be there um it's
really helpful to go there really
helpful sometimes it doesn't mean
anything but even like I did I did what
the Borgia you know even if it's honest
honest it's 14 something I still went to
Rome a new Rome but I went back to Rome
to read it with with the eyes of okay I
have to do st. Peter's have to do st.
Peter's Square even it is not the same
we couldn't copy because the st. Peter
that at that time was that the same one
that it's now so because it's right
after him the demolish and yo and
Colangelo paint the ceiling but at that
time it was it was Silda the early early
church so it was a church from 1800 but
I went to Rome to first of all why not
going sure yeah good good excuse yeah
yeah yeah so I'm not it's it's I did the
many movie that were on the road lot
Japan Tilly we shuttin you know the red
violin five countries so I it's very
good to go there sometimes they say it
won't happen you know nobody wants to
pay you to go a tear but most of the
time you get I don't need to mow I don't
need a doctor to come with me you know
sure you can quite just me and and
trying to and I i knew now i do a lot of
internet but for many years I have a
huge
no it would fill this room so have lots
of book gun so i go there and so for
Brooklyn did you go to Brooklyn and also
Ireland we shot in Darwin so we went
there we scout for maybe two weeks one
week the doctor was sitting in the in
the in the car with us he was very open
and with that's where we really connect
John Crowley yeah it's a little bit
unusual that a doctor would spend like a
week in a car with the designer look
again plication and what were you doing
like where were you going stopping at
different roadside no no no trying to
find the town where she lives and you
know and find a connection house and
because it's it's limited number of
scene but we still she has to go out and
walk to the dance hall and and the
general store you know and so we need
stuff and johnny's irish showing you
more and but we scout and scout and we
end up shooting in a in a scotty which
is it the town that it's written in the
book and the novel the same place by so
we had two or three village and you know
ABC and where we went down down down and
we took it and it Scotty
you